C'est... C'est bien ici Zeste de Science ?
Super bien reçu !
Merci !
C'est super ... super chaud !
[Ben attends un peu]
Moi... Attendre un peu ?
Tu vas me passe une paille,
je vais boire ça, comme une punaise.
Vous allez voir...
Rien de plus agaçant que de devoir
attendre qu'un café refroidisse,
ou qu'une glace ramollisse
avant de les déguster.
Mais on en a fait tous l'expérience.
Essayer de les engloutir direct,
ça peut être... sacrément désagréable.
Alors imaginez un peu le calvaire...
si vous deviez boire des litres d'une
boisson bouillante, le plus rapidement possible.
Hum
Pardon
La vidéo que vous venez de voir est un thermogramme
de la punaise "rhodnius prolixus"
en train de boire du sang de mouton
à travers la paroi d'un alimentateur artificiel.
Ce genre de vidéo permet de révéler la température
et on s'aperçoit ici que,
alors que l'insecte boit du sang à 37°C,
sa température reste de 22°C
dans la majeure partie de son corps.
Heureusement ! Parce que ces punaises ne peuvent pas supporter des excès de chaleur au-delà de 30°C.
Pire !
Si elles étaient plusieurs à proximité,
des voisines pourraient les confondre avec des mammifères gorgés de sang
et commencer à les cannibaliser.
Mais comment font-elles pour éviter le coup de chaud ?
Des chercheurs de l'université
François Rabelais de Tours,
associés à des équipes brésiliennes et canadiennes,
ont découvert leur secret.
Tout se passe au bout du rostre,
la sorte de paille qu'utilise la punaise
pour se gorger de sang.
Haut niveau de la tête,
l’œsophage est collé à une aorte
dans laquelle circulent
les fluides frais de l'insecte.
Cette configuration crée, ce qu'on appelle,
un système d'échanges de chaleur à contre-courant,
et permet de refroidir le sang qu’ingurgite la punaise avant qu'il n'arrive dans son abdomen.
Si je ...
... colle ma paille ...
... sur celle de Léa,
alors que j'apprécie un café moins chaud,
la boisson de Léa lui parviendra plus tiédasse.
Wouuuh
Punaise ! J'ai eu chaud.
Des systèmes d'échange de chaleur à contre-courant,
il en existe dans les chaudières,
dans votre frigo, dans votre climatiseur,
et dans la nature.
On en connaissait dans le museau des gazelles
ou encore dans les nageoires des dauphins,
mais c'est la première fois qu'on en met
en évidence chez un insecte qui boit du sang.
Encore plus fort !
Il semblerait que ces punaises compilent
plusieurs manières d'évacuer le surplus de chaleur
en utilisant un système de refroidissement,
grâce à leur ... pipi.
Si une goutte de pipi reste
au bout de leur abdomen et s'évapore,
cela va leur permettre d'évacuer de la chaleur.
C'est d'ailleurs la même technique
qu'avait mis en évidence l'équipe de chercheurs de l'université François Rabelais de Tours
qui l'avait découverte chez des moustiques anophèles
eux aussi confrontés aux risques de surchauffe
lorsqu'ils nous pompent le sang.
Moustiques et punaises buveurs de sang
sont des vecteurs de nombreuses maladies
comme la malaria qui est colportée par l'anophèle,
ou encore la maladie de Chagas
transmise par cette punaise.
Ouais, je sais c'est chaud.
mais heureusement qu'on en apprend plus
sur leur manière de se nourrir,
pour pouvoir mieux les affronter.
Je vous laisse sur ces espoirs
mais si vous voulez battre le fer
tant qu'il est encore chaud,
vous pouvez nous laisser un commentaire à chaud,
ça nous fera chaud ...
... au cœur.
ça ne me fait ni chaud, ni froid
[Abonnez-vous !]
[Et lisez "Moi, parasite"]